apenas de 200 kilómetros de La Isla
italiana de lampedusa la ciudad tunecina
desfax es el punto de partida de muchas
de las travesías migratorias del
Mediterráneo tunecinos y subsaharianos
que parten hacia Europa
Este ha sido un año récord de salidas
desde desde principios de año hemos
interceptado aquí a más de 17.000
migrantes
este fenómeno se ha duplicado con
respecto a los años anteriores
sus historias son desgarradoras los
traficantes cobran la desorbitada suma
de 1500 euros por el viaje lo que para
muchos de ellos supone un año de ahorros
a menudo solo para ser devueltos no no
estamos aquí porque no encontramos
apartamentos para vivir porque son muy
caros
vivimos una vida muy difícil muy
peligrosa en 2021 Italia llegó a un
acuerdo con el gobierno tunecino a
cambio de una mayor inversión de la
Unión Europea en el país túnez
movilizaría sus recursos para evitar que
inmigrantes e irregulares llegan a las
costas europeas impidiendo las salidas e
interceptando las embarcaciones y
trayendo a sus pasajeros de vuelta a
túnez las embarcaciones incautadas que
antes transportaban inmigrantes están
apiladas en el puerto de fax los
guardacostas tunecinos afirman que no
cuentan con los recursos necesarios para
hacer frente a flujos migratorios que no
dejan de aumentar las cifras oficiales
contabilizan más de 22.500 personas
interceptadas frente de las costas
tunecinas en 2022